le procès en destitution peut-il durer
durablement pardon écorné l'image du
locataire de la maison blanche où
peut-il au contraire remobiliser son
électorat quelles seront les
conséquences c'est l'objet de notre face
à face ce soir et pour en débattre
nous sommes sur ce plateau avec françois
durpaire historien spécialiste des états
unis bonsoir françois à ses côtés paul
rim présidents des républiques mc une
french merci à vous d'être là bonsoir
alors françois durpaire déjà à quoi
doit-on s'attendre le 21 janvier ce que
ça va être le feuilleton le plus
regardée des états unis non mais on
disait qu'il y aurait aucune surprise il
y en a déjà eu il ya déjà eu un élément
s'attendait pas à ce que ça commence si
tard on pensait que ça allait passer
directement de la chambre des
représentants au sénat et pas du tout
vous avez vu ça a été retenu par nancy
pelosi
pour une raison simple nancy pelosi qui
voulait être la maîtresse des horloges
s'est dit si je fais passer ça
directement au sénat ça va être vite
réglé parce qu'on a vu un mitch
mcconnell a le patron des républicains
au sénat dire moi je suis l'avocat de
donald trump n'y aura pas de souci ça va
passer comme une lettre à la poste à la
retenue un petit peu les choses
ce qui fait que là on arrive au sénat
dans un climat un peu différent avec des
républicains qui ne sont pas acculer
mais qui se disent il faut quand même
donner les apparences d'un procès parce
qu'attention c'est pas un tribunal mais
c'est bien un procès c'est un procès
sans tribunal vous appréhendez vous
pèlerine procède de votre poule à un
point c'est une procès je suis content
en fait qu' il y aura un procès et pas
une annulation de procès parce que comme
ça tout le monde
on va voir que les 30 n'est pas coupable
d'un crime et qu'il sera acquitté
il y aura un kit ans et je crois que ça
ça ça sera très bien mais acquitté pour
quelle raison parce que le sénat est
majoritairement républicain ou parce
qu'il n'est vraiment pas coupable parce
qu'il n'est vraiment pas coupable il
faut il faut il faut voir qu'il y avait
deux articles de destitution a signé
hier par nancy pelosi
en gros on fait une grande célébration
même que a dit que c'était une occasion
très solennelle ce n'était pas très
sereine et en plus elle est pour les
démocrates
mais les deux articles ni l'un ni
l'autre est assez fort pour une
destitution et on n'a pas vraiment
discuter encore le détail les deux
hâtive de l'abus de pouvoir et
l'obstruction du congrès qui y avait
beaucoup de scolaires l'iard ligot
qu'ils ont déjà dit que le deuxième
accord obstruction de congrès n'est ces
obscurs et je crois que pendant procès
de sanaa
tout le monde va voir ça françois
durpaire vous partager l'optimisme de
paris tout le monde va voir que tu n'es
pas en gros on ira plus loin dans cette
analyse mais en gros ça peut peut-être
même dû profiter à l'or ce qui se passe
c'est que aujourd'hui les américains se
disent on a on a peut-être la chance de
faire la clarté sur ce qui s'est passé
il ya un peu près 60% des américains qui
se disent bon donald trump joui pendant
toute cette période d'objectivité
c'était pas le cas il ya quelques
semaines et là on a des américains qui
vont regarder quand même ça d'assez près
pas forcément que les spécialistes de
sciences politiques
après l'optimisme sur la fin oui les
républicains vont
vont pas voter contre leur président
simplement peut-être on va avoir un
premier élément c'est est ce que
certains vont être convoquées est ce que
par exemple john bolton ancien directeur
du vous savez que john bolton s'est
peut-être disputé avec on sait pas on
sait pas ce qui s'est passé entre bolton
et le président mais en tout cas les
démocrates veulent la voir john bolton
face à eux et là peut-être que les
républicains pourraient se dire oui
effectivement on veut on va avoir john
bolton mais on veut la réciprocité
on veut avoir aussi hunter by dad on
veut interroger le fils de baye donne
parce que évidemment ça permettra de
mouiller aussi les by day dans cette
histoire on parlera pas que de 2,1 trust
mais on parlera aussi de baden donc il
ya quand même des éléments intéressants
c'est pas écrit d'avancé ce qui est
écrit d'avancé que donald trump restera
président jusqu'à jusqu'à la fin il ya
la durée aussi intéressante parce que si
ça dure cinq semaines comme en 1999 ça
fait un peu long un peu long parade au
gazon pour les démocrates parce que les
démocrates ils vont devoir quand même
commencer leurs élections primaires et
voyez on parle que nous nous invité pour
parler de notre un plat alors que les
démocrates viennent d'avoir un débat
vont s'apprêtait à aller dans l'iowa
pour d'ailleurs on va parler dans
quelques instants françois justement
d'un patin sur la campagne sur le pays
sur les démocrates tout d'abord puisque
ont parlé de l'impact sur donald trump
et sa popularité éventuels on va voir ce
sondage établi par les politiques
s'entre octobre 2019 précisément et
janvier la 2020 l'opinion des électeurs
qui a changé voilà pour ce sondage vous
voyez dans l'opinion des électeurs qui a
changé sur la destitution davantage un
son pour cette destitution est ce qu'on
doit en
tirer une conclusion c'est difficile
parce que l'opinion et c'est assez
fortement polarisé ce qu'on veut dire
sur la popularité de d'un train plat au
moment où on se place c'est que s'il est
il est dans une position
je prends le sondage rasmussen par
exemple et je le compare à barack obama
dix mois avant sa réélection il est à +4
ça veut dire qu'il est dans une position
plus confortable que barack obama avant
sa réélection
je vous rappelle que depuis 1912 on n'a
que trois présidents américains qui
n'ont pas été réélus 11 ont été réélus
les trois vous vous rappelez ces hoover
c'est carter et c'est george bush est la
particularité de ces trois c'est que le
pib avait baissé lors de la dernière
année or donald trump pour l'instant il
semble pas que l'économie s'effondre il
avait mis une bonne nouvelle économique
avec eux cet accord avec la chine on va
pas dire forcément grand chose du fond
parce que vous l'avez abordé par
ailleurs qu'est ce qu'on peut dire c'est
qu'il peut vendre déjà l'accord il te
dire voyez j'ai j'ai résisté à la chine
et il ya des éléments dans ces d'accord
qui permettent de dire que voilà je suis
ça va faire plaisir à je suis sensé de
contredire les obligés de dire voilà
deux dalles tram va quand même vendre
cet accord est la séquence iranienne
c'est facile rania qui était plutôt pas
très bien parti on s'est dit et ce qu'il
est fou qu'est ce qui fait et c est au
final avec effectivement cette ce
dramatique accident il semble que ce
soit un tir accidentel mais surtout avec
le fait que les iraniens et bien ont
riposté sans faire aucun mort américains
et ont tenu à ne pas faire de morts
américains
on peut dire mais finalement il avait
calculé les risques donc on n'est pas
dans un donald trump fou en politique
étrangère mais on est dans un donald
trump qui a calculé les risques donc il
peut vendre cette séquence en politique
étrangère également sur la chine il faut
quand même reconnaître qu' à rien
structurellement qui va changer
la chine va continuer à subventionner
ces entreprises l'état va continuer à
subventionner cette entreprise si
c'était ça le but de donner un train
plat il a échoué alors donald trump qui
prédit ce soir que son procès en
destitution sera très vite bouclée par
win
c'est votre avis aussi que ça va aller
très vite dans notre avis mon procès sur
un poste clé un fou et ça va commencer
début de semaine prochaine
normalement ça va durer jusqu'à une
semaine maxime entendu voilà je suis je
suis innocent et on va vite sans
j'espère qu'il y aura des témoins
c'est une théâtre maintenant donc tout
le monde regarde donc j'espère qu'il y
aura quelque chose à voir
non non j'ai failli tout intéressant
c'est là où quand même eu un peu de
croustillant un peu de rebondissements
françois durpaire vous pensez qu'on peut
quand même apprendre des choses un peu
croustillantes lors de ce point on parle
d'environ trois semaines
tout va dépendre aussi des témoins si
effectivement on a des témoins qui
n'étaient pas à la chambre des
représentants et qu'ils sont au sénat
est effectivement en particulier john
bolton
vous savez qui dénoue veut témoin dix
nouvelles informations
dix nouvelles révélations et dix
possibilités de retournement de ce
procès en tout cas l'historien il est
prudent dans ce qu'on pourrait attendre
vraiment de tellement significatif en
tout cas ce qui pourrait si on en
apprend des choses significatives
ou plutôt si on a des éléments de preuve
vous savez que les démocrates paul a dit
obama discuter du fond de ces chefs
d'inculpation
et quand même quelque chose d'assez
subtil et d'ainsi pelosi a quand même
mis l'accent sur deux chefs
d'inculpation qui sont assez bas on
parle pas de trahison on parle pas de
choses très très élevé on parle de
choses qui sont assez basses et donc qui
laisse la possibilité à une preuve
éventuelle
maintenant est ce que ça va faire
basculer les républicains du côté d'un
nouveau du côté de
du fait que le président devrait quitter
le pouvoir c'est pas ça le but des
démocrates
le but des démocrates c'est pas la
destitution réel c'est le discrédit le
discrédit sur le président mais aussi le
discrédit sur les républicains qui
pourraient être amenées devant l'opinion
indien
nous on cherche à cacher la vérité est
d'ailleurs la preuve mitch mcconnell qui
disait il ya quelques semaines je suis
l'avocat de donald trump ne dit plus du
tout ça aujourd'hui dix on va faire la
vérité on va on va mener un procès dans
les règles et d'ailleurs si vous voyez
là on va peut-être pas se diviser là
dessus mais c'est aussi pour la
constitution américaine alors que d'un
côté on à donald trump qui dit non c'est
pas bien pour la constitution et de le
côté nancy pelosi vizier le président
menace la démocratie est finalement vu
de l'extérieur quand on n'est pas
américain on peut dire que c'est plutôt
une belle leçon démocratie parce qu'on a
d'un côté un président de l'autre côté
un congrès et on a le fameux check and
balance is les freins et contrepoids le
président ne fait pas ce qu'il veut
le congrès il ya un niveau du mollet de
pouvoir et les gares et péages
on est ici dans ce test la constitution
on va écouter d'abord à caullery nous ça
va vous faire très plaisir même si
pelosi est justement présidente
démocrate de la chambre des
représentants qui se justifie sur cette
procédure et côté saad
c'est très triste et tragique et les
actions prises par le président porte
atteinte à la nation viol son serment
d'office et met en péril la sécurité de
leur élection que l'intégrité des
élections et nous et a mené la recherche
d'elle donc aujourd'hui nous entrerons
dans l'histoire lorsque les procureurs
marcheront dans le
enfin nous franchirons une étape
historique en apportant l'acte
d'accusation contre le président des
états unis pour abus de pouvoir et
entrave au travail du congrès et en
entrant dans l'histoire
nous faisons des progrès pour les cadets
américain fait bien comprendre que ce
président sera tenu responsable que
personne n'était au dessus des doigts et
qu'aucun futur président ne devrait
entretenir l'idée que l'article 2 dit
qu'il peut faire ce qu'il veut one qui
théâtralise un petit peu cette procédure
l'accusent donne ça me met d'avoir mis
en péril la sécurité des élections
américaines vous pensez que c'est les
américains vont être sensible à cet
argument on se souvient de bill clinton
qui avait menti et ça avait fait un
énorme scandale aux etats-unis est-ce
que ce type d'accusation est vraiment
très grave aux yeux de vos compatriotes
ballerines
on a déjà vu le procès dans chambre tout
le monde c'est pas le première fois la
semaine prochaine on a déjà vu pendant
le mois de décembre
beaucoup beaucoup des jours avec le
thème - normalement prévu d'avoir un bon
tiers de désinformation qui preuve que
que trempe enfin une crime un nom il y
avait une grande chaîne
ces accusations sont de nature à choquer
les américains vraiment parce que voilà
le côté politiciens qui est peut-être
mais je me fais exprès l'avocat du
diable un métier un peu près avant nous
pour se faire élire est-ce que c'est pas
dans tous les pays et pas si grave pour
le peuple parfois je n'en mange et joue
la prod on ment normalement c'est iman
accusations sérieux mais il faut
comprendre que aux états unis les
démocrates chercher des raisons à
destituer le président chante depuis que
le jour qui était le en 2016 plus de 3
il ya trois ans donc et et chaque fois
avec cette enquête que l'été
une région un peu la russie pendant
trois ans et à une enquête complètement
échec le chèque complète et maintenant
la destitution et tout le monde a vu et
donc quand françois a bien dit avant si
cris produisent et aux états unis les
politiques sont très prisés pour viser
tous les démocrates voudraient que il
est destitué
donc c'est chaque que vous avez montré
avant quand même c'est impressionnant
que et à 5 ans pression de tous les
démocrates sont contre 3 mais quand même
après décembre après la destitution
procès de destitution par le chambre par
les démocrates
le profil est retiré 30 à monter les
nombres des gens des citoyens américains
qui sont contre 7,7 théâtre à monter
vouvray et tu as continué à travailler
et continuons à faire les bons économies
qu'on lance paul audi a signé en pointe
fait en célébration des comme c'était
une grand accomplissement de signer il
destitue les articles de destitution à
la même heure
en même temps hier trompe était en train
de faire quoi signé un accord le premier
accord commercial avec la chine
et c'est très très deux côtés
complètement paupérisée il qui travaille
pour le peuple américain
une qui travaillent contre le président
françois durpaire ça va un petit peu
effectivement nous on a commencé à en
parler tout à l'heure ce retour n'est
peut-être compter démocrate son supposé
commencer leur campagne d'ailleurs deux
candidats un majeur là qui vont être un
peu empêché parce qu'ils vont devoir
rester au procès qui vont pas pour aller
sur le terrain et puis quelque chose
d'assez négatif c'est que
on ne parle que de tram 11 ya que
tremper les rangs trump et la chine
trump et son procès et mais ça c'est l'
avantage institutionnelle du président
on disait le 11 à 3,2 tout à l'heure un
pourquoi les présidents sont réélus vous
avez une partie de la réponse ou ne
parle que du président et en plus d'un
train il attire quand même la lumière
d'accord je l'utilisé à jouer cette
dynamisation par laquelle il a aussi
gagné la rai 1 c'est effectivement
depuis le départ il joue là dessus je
antisystème je suis contre
l'establishment et regarder
l'establishment son rang à moi en même
temps l'establishment républicain il est
complètement du côté de son président là
il joue à plein et les levées de fonds
fonctionne c'est quelque chose qui mais
il ya quand même quelque chose c'est que
quand on regarde très précisément les
enquêtes d'opinion ça oui il ya une
sorte un peu on a répété ça en boucle
depuis le début de son mandat c'est
qu'il a un socle à un sauf qu'il a un
socle il n'a pas fait déçu c'est pas
exactement ça c'est à dire quand on
regarde un peu plus de manière un peu
plus précise les enquêtes d'opinion ont
qu une stat ya des déçus de donald trump
et pas des déçus qu'ils vont pas
forcément revoter pour lui mais qui se
disent oui son style
quand même il ya une présidence qualité
même le fameux ouvriers blancs du
midwest dit quand même et il pourrait
quand même des fois où le président il
pourrait être un peu plus un commandant
chef et ses filiales quand même on lit
ça du côté de son électorat
mais évidemment là où il peut se dire je
suis quand même bien parti c'est que du
côté démocrate c'est encore pire c'est
du côté démocrate et bien on se dit
qu'elle est le candidat
et quand on parle du candidat on parle
pas d'un candidat qui nous enthousiasme
on parle pas d'un candidat qui va
changer le visage de l'amérique
on parle du candidat qui peut battre
donald trump et il n'y a pas si vous
voulez on a eu deux derniers présidents
donald trump et barack obama qui étaient
des personnalités fortes
qu'on soit d'accord avec eux ou pas et
là il sent que chez les démocrates en
tout cas pour l'instant savez il ya
toujours des surprises dans une primaire
on n'a pas un candidat qui se dégage
suffisamment où on se disent bien ce
candidat démocrate va vraiment changer
la mairie qui nous propose quelque chose
d'absolument singulier et de différents
noms pour l'instant des démocrates qui
se disent et que ce sera
joe biden ou est-ce que ce serait mieux
warren islanders pour battre de notre
parce que pour l'instant on n'a pas
trouvé l'équation
personne n'a réussi à le battre
ballerines vous aimeriez voir qui face à
donald trump joe banner en tête mais il
perdre son avance moins on commence de
recommencer à chuter en fait surtout
après le débat de l'autre jour où elle a
dit que l accusé bournisien de sexisme
et c'est tellement rigolo que c'est une
ville de leurs avoirs parce que il n'est
pas sexy money c'est nous c'est surtout
mensonge et je défends bernis 1 207 cas
là elle est en train de chuter que elle
elle a joué la carte du féminisme et
essai c'est les rides ispe désespérés
ont fermé en fait faut être juste
bologhine avec avec elisabeth parade
elle a répondu à un propos de sanders
dix ans il peut pas y avoir deux femmes
présidentes mérité mais il avait
maladresse mais j'suis pas de neil
l'ambassadeur qu'est ce qui se passait
entre les deux donc vous pouvez pas dire
ne pouvait passer que ça que sanders new
line avec un au regard de la discussion
donc vous vous écoutez le milieu marin
qui accuse qui est d'accord avec moi
mais ça c'est pas bon ça non mais bon ça
dépend des cas d'un oui c'est un homme
très grave donc on a tous en avaient
marre sanders a dit
vous allez vous engueuler sur senderos
avait le sentiment que cette procédure
de destitution effectivement elle
suscite pas tant que ça le débat et y
compris d'ailleurs sur ce plateau c'est
quasi un non événement est ce qu'on peut
dire c'est presque ça françois où c'est
un peu exagéré ça sera le mot de la fin
parce qu'on le voit avec un peu de recul
états unis ça suscite quand même un
minimum de passion que boire des
conséquences électeurs se disent où elle
prend un électeur vous lui dites est ce
qu'on est ce qu'on consacre cinq minutes
pour coup pour parler de l'assurance
santé ces cinq minutes pour parler de
l'inpi chemin ils vont dire par des
seuils d'intervention tout à l'heure est
ce que c'est si grave pour les
américains ça va être un feuilleton mais
dans le fond non ça va rien changer ou
va rien changer en fait c'est ça
mobilise comme vous avez dit tout à
l'heure ça mobilise les subsides et est
en fait il n'a pas un candidat démocrate
qui criait l'entousiasme avec le peuple
américain que doit donc je vois pas un
changement de président en 2000 da on
est d'accord mais une semaine en
politique c'est très long c'est vrai
merci françois durpaire merci à vous
aussi merci merci